[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et l'obr 10 et un clavier virtuel qui
permet à tous les golfeurs de jouer au
plus près de leurs capacités en fait on
utilise une intelligence artificielle
qui permet de calculer quelle est la
meilleure façon de jouer n'importe quel
parcours dans le monde pour n'importe
quel golfeur au fur et à mesure qu'on
joue avec l'application
l'application va adapter ses
préconisations stratégique au niveau
exact de la personne en fait le golfeur
amateur il a tendance à essayer des
coûts qui sont assez improbable ou en
tout cas qui ont de fortes probabilités
de le mettre dans la difficulté
donc l'application va ajuster ses
recommandations pour savoir quel club
jouer de manière un peu plus réaliste
par rapport à ses propres capacités
donc l eau gordy et soutenu par airbus
développement qui nous accompagne à la
fois financièrement mais aussi
techniquement
en fait notre algorithme aujourd'hui a
besoin d'avoir un mapping géographique
très précis de chaque parcours et airbus
à des technologies qui permettent à
partir de l'imagerie satellitaire
d'extraire des données qui sont utiles
pour que notre intelligence artificielle
puisse prédire la meilleure façon de
jouer pour un amateur sur ce parcours
le lien avec le territoire saint quentin
en yvelines sont déjà établis d'abord
avec airbus qui est installé à elancourt
et puis avec la communauté
d'agglomération avait peut-être une
implantation de vélo birdie au plus
proche du golf national qui est le
challenge stratégique le plus grand
qu'on est en france pour les golfeurs
amateurs être proche de paris saclay
c'est pour nous une énorme opportunité
parce que c'est là qu'on est au plus
proche des meilleurs talents pour
l'intelligence artificielle pour le
développement informatique
je pense qu économiquement c'est le
meilleur endroit où développé une
technologie telle que la nôtre
les logos redis aujourd'hui ces sept
personnes trois emplois permanents et
puis des freelances on a besoin de se
développer et nous cherchons des
partenaires les partenaires financiers
mais aussi des partenaires
institutionnels voire même des
partenariats avec certaines écoles pour
renforcer le lien et participer à cette
belle aventure qui est l'intelligence
artificielle pour le golfeur
[Musique]